weil sie so erfolgreich um die
kanzlerkandidatur gedrückt haben
ein zeitpunkt dafür ist er hat sogar
mehr als die spd
[Musik]
19 5% jetzt reicht die heute show hat
mit der fdp schon mal einen wichtigen
medienpartner verloren das wäre
nationalrat noch mal durch deshalb lasse
ich mich jetzt in die spd aufnehmen aber
nicht von irgendjemand das muss schon
ein prominenter sein der gerade nicht so
viel zu tun hat frau kraft welche eine
freude endlich ehrlich ja ich will ja
heute mitglied werden
haben sie probleme damit dass sich das
nur aus mitleid machen also es hat
nichts mit dem programm zu tun habe ich
gar nicht gelesen ich mache das nur aus
mitleid als er glaubt die wenigsten
haben programm gelesen sondern müsse
sich eben wenn ich jetzt in eine
arbeiterpartei eintrete was muss ich
dann machen arbeiten anschluss dazu also
ehrlich ja das macht jetzt doch deutlich
unattraktiver der dame von der spd die
riester-rente aufschwatzen lassen wenn
ich jetzt bald genosse den krieg die
verlorene kohle wieder zurück wieso die
riester rente wird ausgezahlt
die private vorsorge in den mittelpunkt
zu stellen war damals richtig jetzt warm
eine schwierige situation wenn die ring
zinsen und jetzt muss man wieder
veränderung vornehmen darauf muss auch
klar sein wenn die spd die 20 knackt
dann trete ich wieder aus
wenn wir einmal sind wir genauso gut
gefangen sagt lange der auch drin
das komme ich denn von ihnen wenn ich
jetzt noch zehn neue mitglieder werben
was mit remy da haben wir immer ganz
gewisse aktionen also man es gibt schon
gute prämien das lohnt sich
manche sind ja schon parat ein jetzt vom
team ja also ich hab auch noch ein paar
formulare da also bei der afg witzen
thermomix
man geht jetzt nicht mal hin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
soll ich machen
vlotho
verbreitet
mit
[Musik]
ich werde das jetzt ich fühle mich
irgendwie schmutzig ist er zum abschied
vor kraft noch gerne einen trinken mit
ihnen war sie so erfolgreich um die
kanzlerkandidatur gedrückt haben ein
zeichen dass die spd im recht gewesen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin stolz irgendwie auch für
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht spd-mitglied fühlen nicht
so allein
jetzt will ich auch andere mit
reinziehen entschuldigung müssten die
spd eintreten haben sie wird in die spd
einzutreten
wahrlich 540 an der sm ausgetreten
möchten sie die spd eintreten
nein man spd zu schwierig ich brauche
jetzt mal ein erfolgserlebnis
[Musik]
entschuldigung möchten sie mit mir über
gott sprechen und damit zurück ins
studio
[Musik]